au cours des dernières semaines le
service de police de la régie
intermunicipale richelieu-saint-laurent
a reçu quatre plaintes d'adolescents qui
disent avoir été victimes de ces
extorsions
les jeunes ne se connaissent pas et ne
vont pas la même école
ce qu'ils ont en commun ils utilisent
l'application instagram et il joue aussi
à fortnight un jeu vidéo en ligne
le super prédateur se faufile dans un
groupe d'amis en ligne et tentent
d'avoir une conversation privée
il leur propose de les aider à graver
les échelons plus rapidement dans les
jeux fortnight c'est lors de ces
conversations privées que le cyber
perdre à part tente d'obtenir des images
intimes ou même d'un certain corps a
obtenu des images un seul des quatre
jeunes qui ont été sollicités un seul a
transmis une image à caractère sexuel
rapidement les parents sont intervenus
et ont alerté les autorités
la police a demandé la collaboration de
la commission scolaire des patriotes
patrol un vraiment un d'éducation auprès
des élèves donc d'adopter des bons
comportements
les médias sociaux sur internet à des
vigiles avec qui on a des contacts dans
les médias sociaux
un courriel a été envoyé aux parents
pour les informer des dangers de l'as
extorsion ce qui a suscité bien des
discussions auprès des jeunes pensent
pas que ça m'étonnerait moi mais c'est
sûr que je pense que pas mal de
personnes qui se laisseraient influencée
par ceux qui comme que je connais pas pu
me dire maintenant je compte au niveau
je le connais pas je peux supporter
meilleures phrases comme moi je te dirai
qui tu es victime de céline le post fois
l'année soit un autre jeu qu'est ce qui
t'as vu belgacom était de largeur ces
choses et manipulations qui était même
allé jusqu'à ce que parra s'il faisait
pas seule ce poids drôle tu sais c'est
atroce comme une chose afin quelqu'un
surtout aux jeunes toqués bino ce genre
de crime est de plus en plus populaire
les policiers de richelieu-saint-laurent
poursuivent leur enquête dans cette
affaire où que suspect n'a encore été
arrêté ici karen bastien radio-canada
beloeil alors voici de faire un peu d'y
voir un peu plus clair la date des faits
il ya donc deux phénomènes l'atonie
clemens une chose les jeunes c'est une
autre chose comment distinguer lead
mercedi dans les deux cas ces palaces
extorsion donc on se sert des photos
intimes pour faire du chantage pour
avoir ce que ce qu'on veut dans le cas
des jeunes semblent garder un des
individus
on lui a demandé encore plus de photos
donc ont utilisé la photo qu'il avait
envoyé pour soutenir encore plus de
photos dans le cas de monsieur clément
semble que c'était plus financer donc on
a demandé 50 mille euros sans quoi on
allait grand public si c'est pour tout
l'eau donc c'est le cas classique soit
de ces extorsions et donc dans lequel
monsieur clymène et dans le cas des
adolescents il le fait d'envoyer la
première photo compromettante
on ne veut on a le bras dans la grenard
exactement c'est sur les stratagèmes
sait qu on mise beaucoup sur en la honte
de la personne de s'être fait avoir et
aussi sur son réseau social donc on dit
généralement ben si tu m'en veut parce
que je veux je vais publier les photos
je les envoyais à ta famille attisera
tes collègues à ton patron à tes amis à
l'école donc vraiment si on it on
utilise le réseau social de la personne
pour prendre la 8c gêné
le bras et c'est facile de dire
peut-être barre c'est des gens qui se
font avoir tant pis pour eux ils ont
juste a pas envoyé des photos de leurs
parties intimes
c'est comme une évidence mais c'est pas
si évident que cela
les gens qui font ça savent comment
trouver des victimes savent où trouver
les victimes aussi donc on sait avec le
cas des jeunes ils ont misé sur le jeu
forte note qui est très populaire auprès
des jeunes
donc ils savent comment cibler les
personnes dans leur école extension les
personnes à qui j'ai parlé qui était
victime de ça bon on voit que les
personnes derrière social comment miser
sur les personnes les plus vulnérables
les personnes qui sont en situation dans
leur vie où ils seraient plus
susceptibles de tomber dans le panneau
alors quoi faire si quelqu'un se fait
prendre l'eau qu'est ce qu'on fait donc
la police est très clair là-dessus ne
faut absolument pas obtempéré donc on
n'en voit pas d'argent on n'en voit pas
plus de photos souvent les gens ont
l'impression que si j'envoie de l'argent
ça va s'arrêter là mais malheureusement
ils ont les photos contre premier temps
dont il rien qui les empêche de
continuer à vous ex-tortionnaire
quelques mots peter quelques années plus
tard donc la police est très clair là
dessus il faut contacter les services
policiers ça ici tout contact avec la
personne il soit dit en passant le seul
espoir se disent que bon c'est
confidentiel ne vont pas informer votre
conjoint ou conjointe votre famille si
vous êtes victime à moins que vous
vouliez les rendent au courant dans le
cas de tony clément et lui croyait
parler à une vraie personne une femme
j'imagine qu'on va y ait plein photos de
cette fable oeil ont créé un personnage
or dès qu'il le lui envoyer une photo
intime où il ya eu cette année rouslan
dix ans donnez-nous 50000 euros sinon
aux destructions tout le monde donc
c'est vraiment des groupes bien
organisés
ouais tout à fait donc il ya des groupes
français un peu partout au monde
on voit surtout ça dans les pays comme
le nigeria et si leur travail il faut
dire ce sont des professionnels souvent
ils savent exactement comment les nazis
tous les boutons pour aller chercher
leurs victimes savent quoi dire pour
faire part à la victime pour qu'elle
envoie de l'argent donc ils savent ce
qu'ils font ensemble comment créer un
faux profil qui est vraisemblable aussi
est-ce que c'est en expansion jeudi
avant la pause on a l'impression qu'à
une peluche le plus très difficile à
dire on en parle de plus en plus donc
c'est bon on en parle mais mon nouvelle
par contre très peu de gens signalent à
la police donc
souvent les gens ont peut être fait
avoir donc les services s'est ainsi dit
ce qu'on sous-estimé peut-être ce
problème là parce que justement les gens
ne vont pas la police mon souhait de
donner de l'argent ou souhaitent tenter
de cacher ça donc c'est assez difficile
mais on n'en parle plus et avec
l'avènement des réseaux sociaux
tout le monde est sur facebook
maintenant ça serait pas surprenant
qu'il y en ait plus en tout cas on le
répète à chaque fois ça semble une
évidence mais ne jamais rien d'envoyer
qu'on ne voudrait pas être publiées
partout publiquement on n'envoie pas des
choses qui sont privés surtout pas des
étrangers des gens qu'on n'a jamais
rencontrés en personne un profil
facebook ou instagram ça peut avoir
l'air très véridique
ça fait penser que c'est une vraie
personne comme j'ai dit ces gens là sont
des professionnels savent comment créer
un faux profil qui a vraiment l'air vif
table donc on fait attention
merci jeff y ait merci beaucoup au
revoir